Speaker 1: . I don't yet know the
reasons why this is happening,
but yesterday morning, Fox News daytime, so
not like the Tucker Carlson, Laura Ingraham,
Sean Hannity stuff. The daytime stuff that they
claim is news seems to have been noticeably more
pro vaccine. Now, we're ultimately going to
come back to the reality about FOX coverage,
about vaccines for months now, which is much like
with the election was stolen, conspiracy theories,
they, while maybe not outright promoting anti
vaccine sentiment, were causing anti vaccine
sentiment under the guise of talking about freedom
and by hosting all sorts of so-called vaccine
skeptics and antibiotics people. So they've sort
of made the bed that they are now sleeping in. But
yesterday I started seeing a number of more
less overtly hostile to the vaccines videos.
Could the explanation be the rubber is meeting
the road and Fox News is actually starting to
worry about litigation because the Delta variant
is spreading. It's increasingly clear that this
is overwhelmingly hitting unvaccinated people. I
don't know what the explanation is, but let's take
a look at a couple of clips. Here is an exchange
on Fox and Friends. Brian Kilmeade continues to be
a very strong vaccine, hesitant voice, although
he admits in this clip that he is vaccinated.
That's a good thing. But here he and Steve Doocy
sort of start mixing it up about vaccination and
the possibility that max masks are coming back on.
Speaker 2: Listen, if you didn't get
a vaccination, that's your choice. And
if you did like I did and and they did.
Speaker 1: So that's good. It's good that he's
saying he got it. It's good that he's saying he
got it. Even if he has all the ifs, ands and buts.
Speaker 2: And maybe you did, then you should not
wear a mask. And if you didn't, if you want to go
cliff diving this weekend, you don't have to check
with me. It seems a little dangerous, but I'm not
going to judge you. And if you go ahead and put
yourself in danger, if you feel as though this
is not something for you, don't do it but don't
affect my life. Ninety ninety nine percent of the
people who are dying from covid are unvaccinated.
Speaker 1: That's a fantastic statistic to be
putting out to this audience. And I am glad.
Listen, when Steve Doocy is the voice
of reason, you know that everybody
around you is making no sense.
Speaker 2: It's their choice.
They don't want to die. So they are the
administration and the government is saying
we need the massive mandate to protect the
unvaccinated. That is not that's not their
job. It's not their job to protect anybody.
Speaker 1: So that is absolutely fascinating
for a couple of different reasons. First of all,
Brian Kilmeade insists, well, Steve, if it's
mostly the unvaccinated getting sick and dying,
that's their choice. And then Steve Doocy says,
well, they don't want to die. Steve Doocy has
hit on something that's really important to some
degree. And I know some in the audience don't like
this perspective to some degree. The anti VAX
people, a lot of these anti-tax Republicans are
just victims of disinformation. And Steve Doocy is
right. They don't want to die. It's not that they
want to be martyred making some kind of weird
political statement by not getting vaccinated
and then dying. But the real whopper here is
when Kilmeade says it's not the government's
job to protect anybody, even small government can.
Conservatives, so-called concede that they don't
want the government involved in almost anything
but where they do want the government involved
is to protect people. Now, stereotypically,
what they mean by that is from foreign threats,
from foreign militaries, from bombs, from
terrorists. But a pandemic is a global and
a domestic threat. It's not a foreign army. It's
a virus, apparently. And Brian Kilmeade mind that
doesn't count or that's a different story.
But they are by encouraging vaccination, the
Biden administration is providing for the common
defense of the country of Americans. It would be,
you know, is Kilmeade OK with the FDA and food
inspection or is it listen, it's people's choice
to just, hey, you know, that chicken might be bad.
The the the romayne or the spinach it might have.
Who knows what we don't need FDA. It's basically
people need to figure out their risk tolerance.
No, that's ridiculous. And I've not heard him
come out against that, although maybe he would.
I don't know. And lastly, although it's mostly
the unvaccinated, it's not only the unvaccinated.
There are people who are vaccinated and will
still get sick and there are people who can't
get vaccinated because of medical conditions.
So the willingly unvaccinated, yes, they
mostly put themselves at risk, but they're also
putting at risk other people immunocompromised
and others also complete blindness to their own
network's role in fomenting this stuff. I mean,
have they seen Tucker's show? Have they seen
Laura Ingraham Show, et cetera? That's part
of the reason that this is going on. But again,
here's another example. Here's another daytime
FOX clip from yesterday where they seem to be
very clearly telling, telling their audience,
go and get vaccinated, mean to them.
Speaker 2: They're going to feel like they're
being punished. The unvaccinated should be wearing
masks in close quarters, but they could also be
something that's recommended rather than mandated.
Speaker 1: Doc, this is the propaganda doctor
who who met with Trump to go over Trump's
cognition. Right. I mean, this this is a full,
full blown Fox News propagandist. But even
he's saying this stuff and I'm glad he is
Speaker 2: a question for you with this Delta
variant spreading across the country and we see
it's affecting the stock markets right now, how
important is it for people to get vaccinated and
where can they get more information on where
to get a shot? It's very important that people
get vaccinated because two shots of Pfizer
or the are the vaccine is still giving you
almost 90 percent protection against this and
ninety five to one hundred percent protection
against hospitalization. Hugely important. You
can get your vaccine from a local pharmacy.
Your physician can tell you where to get it.
They're really all over the place. Very easy
to get a vaccine right now. The public
health centers all have it. There are
vaccine centers still going. We're having
a low compliance rate. The Delta variant
needs to be a wake up call to get vaccinated.
Speaker 1: So this is really, really good that
they are doing that now. Why are they doing it?
Could be fear of a lawsuit. You heard him say, oh,
the stock market was down. I'm Ava. I don't know
why I have this vision of, you know, so some I
don't even want to stereotype someone who doesn't
own any stocks and hasn't wanted the vaccine
hearing. Whoa, whoa, whoa. Wait a second. The
stock market's declining because of uncertainty.
Now I'm going to go and get vaccinated. As funny
as that would be, I don't care what it takes to
get these people vaccinated. And if it's the stock
market going down, whether or not it affects them,
whether or not they own a single fraction of
a share, or whether it's a Fox News doctor
that Trump likes saying go and get whatever it
takes. It's good that a little bit during the day
yesterday, the tide seemed to be turning a little
bit on Fox News. So that's a good thing. We are
very close to the sixteenth anniversary of The
David Pakman Show. I know it's hard to believe.
How could I have started a show when I was
only five years old? It's shocking to you.
It's shocking to my parents. It's shocking
to everybody. But alas, we are almost at our
sixteenth anniversary. And in honor of that,
to celebrate that, we will be doing a one day
membership special at Join Pakman Dotcom.
How can you not miss out? Just get on my
newsletter at David Pakman Dotcom. And then Monday
morning, August 16th, you'll get a beautiful,
perfect email telling you exactly how to
avail yourself of this membership discount.